Let's go through each of these statements to decide whether or not they're each
true. So, first things first, all functions have inverses. Well we know that
that's not true. Some functions, like y equals x squared, don't pass the
horizontal line test. So, this doesn't have an inverse. We can't check this
first one off then. Moving onto the second one, we have all inverse functions
have inverses. This one is true. If we start off with one function, and reflect
it across the line y equals x. If we start off with one function, and then
reflect it across the line, y equals x and end up with another function, then
the second function is the inverse of the first one. But if we reflect the
second one back across the line y equals x again, we'll end up with its
inverse, which is the first one. This is basically the same as the property I
showed you before. If we have a function f inverse that we know is the inverse
of f, and then we take its inverse, that just equals the original function f.
So yes to the second choice. Now third, we have a function's domain can
influence whether or not it has an inverse. This one is definitely true. We saw
this with our parabola, which we took only portions of, and saw that those
portions had inverses, while the whole parabola didn't. And we also saw the
same thing with our absolute value function. Fourth, all functions pass the
vertical and horizontal line tests. Well all functions pass the vertical line
tests. That's how we know that they're functions. But not often past the
horizontal line test. So this isn't true. The last choice however, is true. All
inverse functions pass both the vertical and horizontal line tests. Inverse
functions are functions, so they pass the vertical line test, and since inverse
functions all have inverses as we've already decided, that means they have to
cross the horizontal line test, as well. Now I personally think this was a
really, really tough quiz. This required you to show some very in-depth
understanding of inverse functions, and to think really critically about all of
these statements. Awesome job on this quiz and on the entire lesson.